1953 and Joseph Stalin is dead starlings
previous policies of purging those who
disagreed with him created a climate of
terror meaning his death left everyone
feeling a bit nervous to say the least
his most likely air was Lavrentiy Beria
who ran the internal security forces
which importantly included the secret
police the MGB this wasn't to be the
case since the other potential
successors gyoji Malenkov Stalin's
former deputy in viata Slav Molotov the
Foreign Minister teamed up to remove him
as a result in late 1953 he came down
with a fatal case of being shocked so
which one of these two would succeed
Stalin it was neither since in late 1953
Nikita Khrushchev who was head of the
Moscow branch of the Communist Party
managed to climb to the top of the pile
doing most part to the support of
high-ranking officials and military
leaders the most notable being Field
Marshal Gorky Zhukov instead of doing
what Stalin did in executing his rivals
Khrushchev simply demoted or fired them
as he would later due to Zhukov however
he did follow Stalin's footsteps by
holding the two highest offices in the
USSR simultaneously the first was the
General Secretary of the Communist Party
who was in charge of party doctrine and
importantly who would rise through its
ranks the second was the premier of the
Soviet Union a position which controlled
the government itself an implementation
of communist doctrine and importantly
could give nice jobs with all sorts of
benefits to his allies incidentally
those who thought these bureaucratic
jobs were collectively known as the
nomenclature er and it was immensely
corrupt so crews chopped surly
Premiership was troubled and he wanted
to implement sweeping changes to reform
the USSR one issue was rioting
throughout the system of labor prison
counts better known in the West as the
gulags these riots were repressed but
over the following years many many
prisoners were released back into
society and they promptly told everyone
how Warfel it all was he also partly to
make himself more popular transferred
control of Crimea from the Russian
Authority to his native Ukrainian one in
1956 at the Communist Party Congress
which was a nationwide meeting of
high-ranking party members Khrushchev
denounced Stalin in what is called the
secret speech this criticized Stalin's
use of repression and false trials his
use of mass deportations and his attempt
to create a cult of personality around
himself the pledge was that the USSR and
Soviet Communism in general would need
to change if it was to survive which I
should in a period known as
de-stalinization this doesn't mean that
the USSR was suddenly a free nation it
wasn't and it still didn't tolerate
dissent
it was simply less likely to shoot you
for it instead a person who now held
what would deemed to be socially
dangerous
opinions would simply lose their jobs
that were forcibly admitted to
psychiatric hospitals so the 1950s and
early 60s were a time of great change
for the USSR and Khrushchev led several
initiatives to enact such change he was
in office when the USSR detonated its
first hydrogen bomb a more powerful form
of nuclear weapon and also when Sputnik
the first artificial satellite was
launched into orbit 1961 saw the
greatest triumphs of the Soviet space
program when the USSR became the first
nation to achieve manned spaceflight
after putting your Gagarin into orbit it
should be noted that the Soviet space
program was less about carrying
satellites and men into space and more
about testing rockets to see if they
could carry the aforementioned hydrogen
bombs to America where they would
promptly explode Khrushchev also
spearheaded agricultural reform in what
was called the virgin land initiative he
sought to harness technological advances
to create a large belt of farmland
these virgin lands were to be planted
with the special crop corn which
Khrushchev was a little bit obsessed
with initially corn did very well but
after some bad weather corn harvests
were devastated and Khrushchev looked
like an idiot with respect to foreign
policy Khrushchev had to deal with many
crises Khrushchev aimed for a policy of
peaceful coexistence with the West
because as far as he was concerned the
march of progress would inevitably end
with capitalism losing out to communism
his aims were undermined however when a
speech he gave on the matter included
the famous line we will bury you which
sounded a little bit like a threat in
the Warsaw Pact made up of the USSR's
communist puppet state uprisings against
Soviet overlordship broke out in 1956
the most notable being in Hungary which
were fiercely crushed 1961 was an
especially troublesome year for
Khrushchev there was the u2 crisis which
saw America continue to fly
reconnaissance missions over the USSR
despite its protests it also saw the
Berlin crisis where in US and Soviet
tanks have a tense standoff for
checkpoint charlie in the co occupied
city leading to the construction of the
Berlin Wall furthermore 1961 was the
year of the sino-soviet split in which
Chairman Mao and the People's Republic
of China denounced the USSR and its
leaders as traitors to the Communist
cause of course the most famous event of
Khrushchev's Premiership occurred in
1962 the Cuban Missile Crisis this was
when he agreed to place nuclear weapons
in Cuba at the request of Fidel Castro
its new communist leader America was not
happy with the idea of having hostile
nuclear weapons so close and so brocaded
Cuba as Soviet ships approached it
looked like nuclear war was on the
horizon but cooler heads prevailed in
the ships
back in the end it was agreed that the
USSR would remove weapons from Cuba and
in return the US would secretly remove
nuclear weapons from some NATO States
publicly it looked like the USSR had
simply backed down though which may
Khrushchev look weak and his reputation
was badly damaged his reforms and the
fact that he didn't consult other party
members on policy was deeply unpopular
and so in 1964 he was ousted from power
and forced into retirement he did get to
live though so that was nice he was
replaced by Leonid Brezhnev who had less
direct power than his predecessors and
would consult other high-ranking party
members Brezhnev became the general
secretary in the Premiership went to his
close ally Alexei Kosygin both of these
men were unhappy with Khrushchev's
previous liberalizing reformers and
sought to undo many of them one means of
doing this was to enforce stricter
standards on the Warsaw Pact the most
notable being Czechoslovakia who had
recently relaxed their censorship laws
this was unacceptable and so with the
assistance of some other members of the
Warsaw Pact the USSR invaded and put an
end to any reforms there this sort of
intervention in other communist states
form the backbone of Soviet foreign
policy known as the Brezhnev Doctrine
under Brezhnev the USSR famously entered
a period of economic stagnation there
are many reasons for this the first was
that prices were fixed by the central
government meaning that prices can be
adjusted to prevent losses another was
that corruption was rampant something
which Brezhnev was happy to ignore
economic stagnation led to my old social
turmoil as many in the USSR became fed
up with worsening living conditions some
men such as Andrew Sakharov became
outspoken critics of the government in
particular the USSR's military and
nuclear policies another was Alexander
Solzhenitsyn whose most famous work the
Gulag Archipelago was published in the
West and detailed life in the gulag had
condemned the communist party for its
role in said system Solzhenitsyn was
kicked out of the USSR in 1974 and
Sakharov was exiled to Gorky here so
economic stagnation dominated the
Brezhnev Ihram was exacerbated by the
high levels of military spending which
was supposed to keep the USSR in line
with the USA by this point both sides
had amassed giant nuclear arsenals and
so they tried to calm the situation by
pursuing a policy called a taunt
this was where both sides would actively
improve relations with each other and
reduce their nuclear arsenals which was
done by the 1969 salt 1 treaty in the
1975 Helsinki Accords the tante came to
an end though in 1979 when Brezhnev
ordered the invasion of Afghanistan to
prop up the failing communist government
there long story short it was an
expensive ten-year disaster Brezhnev
wouldn't live to see the end of the war
in Afghanistan
he died in 1982 was replaced by Yuri
Andropov the head of the KGB and
rip-offs all relations with the USA in
its President Ronald Reagan deteriorate
since both took a hard line towards the
other Andropov died in 1984 and was
succeeded by Konstantin Chernenko as the
general secretary geneco continued the
same policies but would only be an
office for 13 months and he died in 1985
the reasons why these men died so
quickly after taking office was simple
they were old in fact their successor
Mikhail Gorbachev was the only Soviet
leader who was actually born in the
Soviet Union
ie after 1922 so Gorbachev was desperate
to undo the economic stagnation of the
previous decades which had seen the US
economy grow to twice the size of the
Soviets the USSR still had the second
largest economy in the world though but
slow growth meant maintaining its
international position was unsustainable
for the first three years of his
Premiership Gorbachev instituted several
reform packages to kick-start the Soviet
economy and secure the USSR's future
these were perestroika meaning
restructuring glasnost meaning openness
and demócratas axiom meaning
democratization these combined were
designed to make the USSR more
economically decentralized less censored
and allowed for some limited elections
involving non-communists ultimately this
was supposed to reform the USSR so that
it would stay together and grow stronger
but fun fact
no openness for the press led to many
Soviet citizens finding out just how
much worse off they were than the
capitalist counterparts and were made
aware of any incompetencies in the
government one example was made public
in April 1986 when a nuclear reactor at
Chernobyl exploded what really shocked
the soviet population was that they
didn't hear about it for two weeks
meaning that the government was happy to
censor disasters democratization gave a
potential voice to all of this newfound
discontent in almost universally when
communist candidates running against non
communist independence they lost so 1989
was a major year for Gorbachev in the
soviet union gorbachev denounced
repression and permitted free elections
within the warsaw pact which led to its
collapse in the end of the communist
governments there within a couple of
years back in the USSR nationalism a
dissatisfaction with communism
destabilize the country massively
one-party rule was formally ended and
soon after this our March the 11th 1990
Lithuania declared itself to be
independent and others to cled their
intention to leave as well democratic
reforms were quickly implemented which
opened the way to presidential elections
in the numerous national territories
within the USSR 1990 also saw the rise
of Boris Yeltsin who would publicly quit
the Communist Party in
announced Gorbachev's leadership in June
of 1991 Russia held its first ever
presidential election in which Yeltsin
won many leading communists were
horrified by this and so led by Gennady
and I if they launched a coup on August
19th to overthrow the government and
restore the Communist Party to full
power
it was defied in the coup lasted only
two days Latvia and Estonia declared
themselves independent during the
turmoil in three days after the coup
Gorbachev disbanded the Communist Party
by the 1st of December these nations had
declared their independence and on the
21st the Almer at our protocol was
signed declaring the dissolution of the
Soviet Union on the 25th Gorbachev
resigned as the president of the USSR
and on the next day the new government
of the Russian Federation led by Yeltsin
took over its duties thus ending the
Soviet project and beginning the long
transition to a capitalist economy nor
the trials that came with it I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching and a special thanks to James
Bissonnette sol invictus and dante of
Livonia for supporting the channel if
you'd like to learn more about the
dissolution of the Soviet Union there
are some book recommendations in the
description below
you